bien nous allons donc parler ensemble de
climat d'émissions de co2 et d'économie
alors vous peut-être vous pouvez vous
interrogez bizarre pourquoi inviter un
économiste parler du climat et
effectivement il ya encore vingt ans en
2000 on m'aurait demandé qu'est ce que
c'est que l'effet de serre je suis pas
sûr que j'aurais su répondre mais j'ai
changé complètement mon activité
professionnelle d'économistes dans les
années 2000 j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer des climatologues des gens
qui travaillent sur la science du climat
et qui nous explique la question du
changement climatique
écoutons les cinq minutes car si
l'économie ce ne n'est pas capable
d'écouter les climatologues et risque de
dire beaucoup de bêtises sur le climat
nous accumulons dans l'atmosphère un
stock de gaz à effet de serre dont le
principal est le co2 et ce stock
il est là pour longtemps
ce stock nous l'augmentons chaque fois
que nous émettons du co2 ou d'autres gaz
à effet de serre et puis le milieu
naturel va au contraire stocker une
partie du co2 qui est dans l'atmosphère
dont les océans et dans la nature avec
les plantes la photosynthèse
ce que nous disent les climatologues
c'est que si nous ne sommes pas capables
très rapidement de complètement modifier
le fonctionnement de ce système du
carbone en visant la neutralité carbone
dans le monde à savoir si nous ne sommes
pas capables d'avoir une société dans
laquelle le montant de nos émissions
sera au moins au niveau de la captation
dans l'océan et dans les plantes nous
allons vers des risques climatiques
considérable et le dernier rapport du
giec nous rappelle que nous n'avons pas
de temps il faut aller très vite
alors que faire pour transformer notre
économie qui aujourd'hui rempli
l'atmosphère de gaz à effet de serre
pour aller vers une économie qui sera
neutre en carbone et le faire vite
alors il faut faire de grandes choses la
première c'est conserver la capacité du
milieu naturel à stocker le carbone les
forêts l'océan et puis simultanément il
faut drastiquement et rapidement réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
notamment toutes celles qui viennent de
l'énergie qui est la première source de
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
alors interrogeons-nous comment
fonctionne aujourd'hui d'économie et
souvent lorsqu'on parle de ces grandes
questions climatiques on va les regarder
la chine l'inde qui sont des pays
effectivement ou l'augmentation des
émissions très fort mais regardons chez
nous 2015 2016 2017 embellie de
l'économie
ça va mieux vous moins mal qu'avant
suivant qu'on est optimiste ou
pessimiste
et puis il vient s'ajouter un autre
phénomène
baisse du prix du pétrole contre choc
pétrolier nos émissions augmentent en
2015 en 2016
en 2010 est donc dans le fonctionnement
actuel de l'économie
lorsque l'économie va mieux est ce que
le prix l'énergie est bas nous
augmentons rapidement nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et nous accentuons
dramatiquement le changement climatique
et nous prenons du retard car les
climatologues nous explique que
l'horloge climatique tourner
irrémédiablement et chaque année des
missions supplémentaires va retarder
l'avènement de cette société neutre en
carbone alors que peuvent faire les
économistes c'est là que peut-être nous
avons une certaine utilité avec nos amis
les climatologues grâce à à ses
rencontres avec l'imac comme des
climatologues j'ai créé la chaire de
recherche d'économies du climat et nous
travaillons avec beaucoup de jeunes sur
comment changer les règles de l'économie
pour faire en sorte que demain nous
ayons une économie qui lorsqu'on va
mieux eux
eh bien on conduisent on accélère les
élus les réductions d'émissions au lieu
de les augmenter
comment faire nous autres économistes
on est intéressée par les échanges les
prix et lorsque je regarde le
fonctionnement de l'économie je vois que
les prix sont loin d'exprimer toutes les
valeurs environnementales
lorsque nos grandes compagnies
pétrolières importe du pétrole et le
raffine elle paye un prix du pétrole
d'un coup du raffinage mais où est le
coût associé aux émissions de co2 le
coût du changement climatique
il n'est pas dans les prix lorsque nous
autres citoyens
nous faisons nos choix sur les produits
que nous achetons au l'alimentation pour
le transport et l'énergie
lorsque nous faisons notre plein de
fioul pour le chauffage l'hiver le gaz
et des carburants
la valeur associée aux dégâts
climatiques
elle est que très faiblement intégrés
dans les prix comment faire changer le
système des prix comment changer le
système des prix intégrer dans les
valeurs qui s'échangent au plan
international au plan national les coûts
associés aux dégâts environnementaux
qu'il s'agit sûrement climatique ou
qu'il s'agisse des dégâts
environnementaux locaux en france l'
agence sanitaire nationale nous dit que
pour 2016 68 mille décès prématurés
c'est un coût considérable
c'est pas dans les prix du gas-oil qu'on
achète donc nous autres économistes ou
pensons que il faut effectivement
intégré la valeur de l'environnement
dans les prix via des mécanismes qui
peuvent être soit de la taxe soit des
marchés de permis
pourquoi le fait pas et pourquoi c'est
si difficile de le faire ou des raisons
de justice pour des résident des raisons
d'équité
deux exemples la france il ne vous a pas
échappé que actuellement il y a quelques
difficultés dans l'augmentation de la
taxation du carbone et du diesel qui se
cristallise sur les carburants
pourquoi parce qu'il n'ya pas les
mesures d'accompagnement social et de
redistribution nécessaire or une taxe
carbone et anti redistributive
en moyenne les riches consomment plus
d'énergie que les pauvres mais en
proportion du budget du ménage
le coût de l'énergie bien plus élevé et
si vous avez des faibles revenus et
qu'en plus vous êtes loin du centre
ville depuis trente ans nos politiques
ont consisté à sortir les pauvres des
centre-villes pour les mettre dans le
milieu périurbain
vous êtes encore beaucoup plus affectées
donc dans notre pays il faut absolument
accélérer l'augmentation de la taxation
du carbone et des nuisances
environnementales si nous voulons aller
dans le sens de ce que nous disent les
climatologues
mais il faut le faire avec un
accompagnement social beaucoup plus
importants pour éviter que ces systèmes
de valorisation de l'environnement ne se
fasse au détriment de la justice
prenons le plan international vous avez
tous entendu parler des conférences
climatique sous l'égide de l'onu et
notamment celle de paris en décembre
2015 qu'elle est fondamentalement le
problème posé
si nous voulons que l'économie
internationale change son fonctionnement
intègrent la question du climat dans les
échanges entre les pays aboutissent à
des choix radicalement différent en
matière énergétique
et aujourd'hui on a les technologies le
coût du solaire est en train de
s'effondrer
la question l'hydrogène qui est une
question très intéressante fait des
progrès très grand le stockage de
l'électricité fait très grand fait des
progrès qu'est-ce qui manque un levier
économique un prix international du
carbone qui fasse que dans les échanges
mondiaux dans les tous les flux
incroyable qui vont d'asile en europe en
amérique du nord on intègre dans les
échanges la valeur des dommages associés
au climat et on aura une économie qui va
fonctionner complètement différemment
pourquoi on n'arrive pas à le faire ou
pourquoi c'est si difficile à le faire
parce que au plan international la même
question se pose entre les pays à une
autre dimension
entre les pays riches et les pays
pauvres et si nous voulons avoir une
valeur international du carbone qui
guide les grandes décisions économiques
il faut associer à cette valeur
international du carbone ce prix
international du carbone un énorme
mécanismes de redistribution
depuis les riches vers les pauvres avec
un nombre croissant de pays qui sont la
classe intermédiaire qui faubourg et ça
c'est très difficile à obtenir
parce que beaucoup de périgée beaucoup
de sa sévérité et riches en cordes et de
changer leur mode de vie et leurs
privilèges
donc la question de la justice
climatique est une question absolument
essentiel est liée à la tarification du
carbone et le travail des économies
c'est le travail des jeunes chercheurs
de la chaire et du clic aux demies du
climat consiste à essayer de trouver les
mécanismes qui vont permettre de
concilier l'efficacité économique la
justice climatique international et la
réduction massive des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre pour aller vers une
société neutre en carbone qui est
l'objectif que nous assigne les
climatologues
et si demain nous parvenons à changer
les mécanismes de l'économie
grâce à cette tarification du carbone
associées à de l' arc distribution et de
la justice climatique le fonctionnement
de l'économie va complètement changer et
on va passer de l'impossible actuelle
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
qui augmente 2015 2016 mais 17 parce que
l'économie va mieux au possible une
économie bas carbone dans laquelle on va
intégrer dans nos décisions économiques
que nous soyons des ménages ou des
entreprises ou des états la valeur du
climat nos échanges
et pour y parvenir un immense effort de
justice et de redistribution est
absolument indispensable de l'impossible
au possible grâce au prix du carbone